Transcription: Elisabeth Buffard
Relecteur: eric vautier
Bonsoir.
Sébastien Véron, je suis
chirurgien vasculaire à Saint-Étienne.
Je suis stéphanois
maintenant depuis huit ans.
Il ne vous a pas échappé
que ces dernières années,
la technologie est rentrée
dans nos vies de façon imposante,
dans notre vie de tous les jours.
Et c’est également le cas
au bloc opératoire
et au bloc opératoire
à Saint-Étienne en chirurgie vasculaire.
Je ne peux pas vous expliquer
pourquoi j’ai eu une salle de toute
dernière technologie cette année
sans vous expliquer un tout petit peu
ce que c’est que la chirurgie vasculaire.
Je vais vous parler -
en tout cas au début -
comme je fais avec la quasi-totalité
de mes patients qui s’intéressent
un petit peu à ce qu’on va leur faire
et qui sont très demandeurs,
et ça va être assez basique.
Ce n’est pas un cours,
ça ne va pas être scolaire
pendant toute la présentation,
mais vous êtes obligés
d’avoir ça comme fondement
pour comprendre que je fais dans la vie.
En fait, c’est très simple :
on a du sang, c’est le carburant,
c’est ce qui fait fonctionner
notre cerveau, notre cœur,
tous nos muscles, tous nos organes.
On a une pompe, le cœur,
qui va pousser le sang
et qui va l’envoyer vers tous ces organes.
Et pour aller du cœur aux organes,
il faut des tuyaux : les artères.
Pour ceux qui font un peu de mécanique,
ce sont les durites.
Aujourd’hui,
on va s’intéresser aux artères
parce que ces nouvelles technologies,
ça permet de traiter
principalement les artères,
mais c’est ça qui va nous intéresser.
Les veines, c’est pour que le sang
retourne se faire oxygéner
dans les poumons.
Très simple.
Qu’est-ce que ça fait ?
On va garder l’analogie de la voiture :
quand vous marchez,
quand vous êtes au repos
ou vous marchez lentement,
vous consommez très peu.
Quand vous accélérez, vous consommez plus,
il faut du carburant,
il faut de l’oxygène.
Si vous commencez à marcher
beaucoup plus vite, vous consommez plus.
Si vous êtes en montée, bien évidemment,
comme votre voiture,
au lieu d’être à 5 l/100 km,
elle va passer à 15 litres.
C’est la même chose pour les muscles.
Vous marchez, il n’y a pas d’oxygène,
vous avez une douleur,
vous êtes obligé de vous reposer,
votre muscle se repose,
ré-emmagasine un peu de carburant,
un peu d’oxygène et vous repartez
pour la même distance.
Qu’est-ce qu’il se passe
si c’est encore plus bouché ?
Si c’est encore plus bouché,
c’est l’infarctus.
On en entend beaucoup parler pour le cœur,
mais c’est la même chose pour le cerveau
et pour les jambes.
Je vous enlève tout de suite cette photo,
elle n’est pas très jolie.
La peau nécrose,
tout ce qui est en dessous nécrose
et ça peut aboutir à l’amputation.
Je ne peux pas faire ce type de topo
sans vous faire un petit peu de prévention
et vous expliquer
ce qu’il ne faut pas faire, quand même.
Ce ne serait pas mon rôle,
je ne suis pas essentiellement chirurgien.
Tous ceux qui fument
ont vu ces images affreuses
sur les paquets de cigarettes.
Fumer, ça bouche les artères :
les artères du cœur,
mais aussi les artères des jambes,
les artères des reins, etc.
Quand on a l’artérite,
les maladies des artères,
il faut s’arrêter de fumer.
Le sucre : le diabète est un gros,
gros pourvoyeur d’artériopathie.
Et évidemment, déjà avant d’être malade,
il faut faire attention,
mais quand on est malade,
il faut se traiter.
Le beurre, le cholestérol :
évidemment, on en entend beaucoup parler.
Il faut manger sainement
et prendre les fameuses statines
dont on a beaucoup,
beaucoup entendu parler.
Ça paraît évident.
L’hypertension : à chaque fois
que votre cœur pousse le sang,
si la tension est trop forte,
il donne des coups sur vos artères,
ça les lèse à chaque battement du cœur.
Il faut la traiter.
Et l’hérédité, ça,
vous ne pouvez pas le faire.
Mais une fois
que vous avez arrêté de fumer,
fait attention à votre alimentation
fait beaucoup de sport,
marche et de l’exercice,
de temps en temps, ça ne suffit pas
il faut un chirurgien.
Et le chirurgien - D’habitude,
je me présente comme ça
auprès de mes malades,
je suis le plombier de service.
C’est un peu plus facile
qu’un plombier, parce qu’en plomberie,
quand ça coule, on a beau
mettre le doigt, ça continue à couler.
En chirurgie vasculaire, quand ça saigne,
si on met le doigt, ça s’arrête.
C’est beaucoup plus simple pour nous.
Mais évidemment, la simplicité,
ce n’est pas toujours ça.
Notre corps humain
est fait de centaines d’artères.
Il faut pouvoir se déplacer,
comprendre comment ça fonctionne.
Et c’est là qu’interviennent
les nouvelles technologies.
Mon histoire, parce qu’on raconte
un peu tous son histoire actuellement.
Quand j’étais petit, je voulais
faire de l’orthopédie.
Je voulais jouer avec des perceuses
des scies, des visseuses,
couper des os, mettre des clous.
Et bizarrement,
quand j’ai commencé ma chirurgie,
c’était en chirurgie vasculaire,
on m’a dit que c’était une bonne école,
et qu’il fallait
ne pas avoir peur du sang.
Je suis tombé tout de suite amoureux
de cette spécialité
parce que c’était très, très rigolo.
On faisait des grosses incisions -
je ne sais pas si on voit -
on incisait les gens sur un mètre,
on mettait
trois ou quatre chargeurs d’agrafes,
ça fait 90, 100 agrafes, et puis voilà.
Au bout du compte, malheureusement,
on arrive souvent à l’amputation,
ou on arrivait souvent à l’amputation.
Pourquoi je vous dis « on arrivait » ?
A la fin de la première partie
de mon cursus,
qu’on appelle l’internat,
au bout de cinq ans,
on présente sa chirurgie générale
et on arrive tout fier avec son dossier
de toutes les interventions où on
a été numéro un comme opérateur.
Moi, je suis arrivé
avec 50 ou 60 amputations majeures.
Une amputation majeure,
c'est cuisse ou jambe.
J’ai dit : « Quand même,
ce n’est pas mon futur métier,
je ne vais pas faire ça toute ma vie,
ça n’est pas possible ! »
Dans l’imaginaire des gens,
l’amputation, c’est un geste de chirurgie
orthopédique avec nos vis, etc.
Pas du tout !
Les gens qui coupent des jambes, ce sont
les chirurgiens vasculaires, c'est nous.
Je me dis : « On doit pouvoir
quand même faire un petit peu mieux. »
Et à ce moment-là,
c’est le moment où, en chirurgie -
En cardiologie, c’était déjà
beaucoup développé :
on mettait des petits ressorts
dans les artères du cœur,
mais c’est le moment où c’est arrivé
d’une manière assez massive,
dans les artères périphériques,
dans les jambes, dans les reins, etc.
La France avait un petit peu de retard
à ce moment-là.
C’est là que je m’y suis
beaucoup intéressé.
Alors, qu’est-ce que c’est ?
En gros, on va glisser des petits ressorts
en métal dans les artères
et on va utiliser
des petits ballonnets pour ouvrir.
Mais pour faire ça, évidemment,
il faut aller voir à l’intérieur
du corps et se diriger dans le corps.
Je vais vous dire, on n’a pas trouvé
mieux depuis Marie Curie.
En gros, c’est la radiologie
qui va nous permettre
de nous déplacer dans le corps,
on fait des radios.
La radio, c’est une source
de rayonnement, un film.
On traverse le corps et on fait une radio.
Là, l’image n’est pas très bonne,
mais c’est une radio pulmonaire
et ça nous permet de voir les différentes
densités des organes, des os.
Ici, c’était une balle.
C’est exactement la même chose
qu’on utilise un siècle plus tard
au bloc opératoire.
Sauf que la machine a un peu évolué
et qu’elle est mobile,
elle est beaucoup plus petite,
et au lieu d’avoir un film,
une photo papier,
on a une image sur un écran en continu.
Mais la technologie est toujours
la même en deux dimensions.
Qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
Le problème, c’est qu’on n’est pas
en 2 dimensions, on n’est pas à plat.
Vos artères, vos organes,
tout est tortueux, arrondi.
Ça a un volume.
On a -
Il faut qu’il y ait un volume.
On a la radiographie de bassin à plat,
et la réalité, ça va être ça.
C’est un vrai problème pour nous
puisqu’on a une vision en deux dimensions.
Qu’est-ce qui nous a permis
d’avoir la trois dimensions ?
C’est le scanner.
Le scanner, je vais vulgariser.
Qu’est-ce qu’un scanner ?
Un scanner, c'est une trancheuse.
On prend un corps humain et on le découpe.
Et ça nous fait 100, 200, 300…
Maintenant, nos machines nous donnent
entre deux et trois mille tranches
pour aller du nombril au bout des orteils.
Quand on a ces tranches,
on a différentes densités,
on a des os, mais on peut voir
des muscles, on peut voir des intestins.
Ici, ce sont les vaisseaux,
c’est ça qui m’intéresse.
Pourquoi on les voit ?
Parce qu’on injecte un produit
qui se voit à la radiographie,
parce que le scanner, ça fait
des radiographies en tranches.
Ce produit qui est radio-opaque,
c’est comme ça qu’on l’appelle,
ça s’appelle l’iode.
L’iode, on en entend beaucoup parler,
c’est un liquide transparent,
hyper visqueux,
qui se voit très bien à la radio,
mais qui est très toxique pour nos reins.
Si vous n’avez pas de problèmes rénaux,
ça n’est pas toxique,
mais dès qu’on commence
à avoir des problèmes,
c’est un produit très toxique, il faut
l’injecter en très faible quantité.
Qu’est-ce qu’on fait de ces tranches ?
Maintenant,
nos ordinateurs sont ultra-puissants.
Ces tranches, on les prend -
c’est de la 2D -
On accumule les coupes
et on en fait ce qu’on en veut.
On peut en sortir des os,
mais on peut en sortir la peau si on veut.
C’est ce que font les archéologues
pour éviter d’ouvrir les sarcophages.
On peut les utiliser comme ça,
et ce qui m’intéresse, moi,
c’est de ne prendre que les vaisseaux,
que le produit que j’ai injecté.
On a un moule
qui est en trois dimensions maintenant.
On peut le tourner.
Je ne vous ai pas mis de vidéo,
mais de coupes à plat,
on en a fait un moule trois dimensions.
Pourquoi c’est important ?
Parce que mon malade,
sur ma table d’opération,
il va être à plat et je vais essayer
de lui mettre ces vaisseaux,
je vais lui coller sur les artères.
Qu’est-ce que ça donne ?
C’est la réalité augmentée,
ce sont les oreilles de lapin,
c'est les petits rennes, etc.
Ce sont les Pokémon Go
sur la place Jean-Jaurès ou au Colisée.
C’est la même chose au bloc opératoire.
Vous voyez ici - c’est vrai
que la lumière est un peu forte -
on a ici un moule osseux en rouge.
On a pris notre scanner.
Il y a un gros travail maintenant
de console et de reconstruction.
Donc il y a toute une partie informatique.
Comme les skieurs,
les pilotes de Formule un,
on commence par visualiser en 3D
sur l’informatique ce qu’on va faire
et on fait ce qu’on appelle
un moule osseux.
Ce moule osseux, on va le recaler
avec la réalité.
Vous voyez, ici, c’est mon image à plat.
Je vais faire une image à plat,
puis une autre dans un autre angle.
On va bouger plusieurs fois
et puis finalement on va recaler.
Vous voyez l’os.
Vous voyez que je suis en train
de faire différentes radiographies.
Tout se passe avec des commandes,
on appuie sur des boutons,
on a des tablettes
et je vais enlever mon masque
puisque j’ai réglé l’os avec l’os.
J’enlève l’os et je vais
mettre mon vaisseau.
Vous voyez que mon vaisseau
n’est plus à plat maintenant -
on ne le voit plus, on n’y voit plus rien.
Mon vaisseau n’est pas à plat,
on le devine maintenant
Notre cerveau, maintenant.
c’est comme ce qu’on voit à la télé,
les films en 3D, les films d’animation.
On a une image à plat,
mais on sait que c’est du volume
et notre cerveau raisonne bien mieux.
Quel est l’intérêt ?
Je n’ai plus besoin d’injecter
ce fameux produit toxique.
Il n’y a plus besoin d’iode puisque
mon informatique me donne des images.
Donc je fais confiance
à des zéros et des uns,
pour aller soigner et traiter quelque
chose d’assez grave chez un patient.
Ça, c’est la fusion et la trois dimensions
au bloc opératoire.
Pourquoi c’est arrivé ?
Pourquoi je vous parle aujourd’hui ?
Eh bien parce que, à l’HPL, on a eu
la chance d’avoir une première mondiale,
d’avoir la première implantation
de salle avec de l’imagerie 3D,
la toute dernière machine
de chez General Electric.
Pourquoi General Electric est venu
à Saint-Étienne et m’a proposé ça ?
D’abord General Electric,
c’est une grosse société américaine
qui a en particulier
une énorme division médicale.
Il y a une trentaine d’années,
ils ont racheté une société française
qui faisait de l’imagerie
de bloc opératoire de cardiologie.
General Electric a continué à faire
toute sa recherche et développement,
et toute la production mondiale.
C’est-à-dire que même les Américains,
quand ils achètent ce type de machines,
ils les font venir de France
et c’est fabriqué à Buc,
en région parisienne, à Saint-Quentin.
Que s’est-il passé ?
En octobre 2021, au RSNA,
c’est la grande réunion internationale
de radiologie à Chicago -
on voit un petit bout de -
je ne sais plus où c’est -
de General Electric, c’est énorme.
J’y suis allé une fois, mais c’est -
Il faut imaginer dix ou vingt fois
le Centre des congrès.
C’est colossal.
Ils ont présenté la nouvelle machine,
la nouvelle génération,
qui va être développée et vendue
pour les dix ou quinze prochaines années.
Pour Noël, ils sont venus voir Véron,
qui est un petit peu le geek de service,
et ont dit : « On veut faire un cadeau,
on voudrait implanter la première salle
chez vous parce qu’on vous aime bien. »
Surtout parce que je suis un gros geek
et que je m’intéresse énormément
à cette technologie et que l’intérêt -
Je travaille beaucoup avec eux,
avec leurs ingénieurs, etc.
Ils ont dit : « Si vous voulez,
on vous l’implante. »
Pour m’avoir, c’est simple,
ils m’ont apporté, ils m’ont montré
toute une brochure comme ça.
Quand vous voyez ça, c’est le 15 décembre,
vous allez voir le Père Noël d’ici peu.
Vous avez les yeux qui brillent.
Je suis rentré, ma femme m’a dit :
« Tu te fais avoir, arrête d’acheter,
ils t’ont vu venir. »
Au bout de dix quinze jours,
ils ont dit : « Si vous signez
avant le 28 décembre,
on vous fait vraiment un bon prix
parce qu’on vous aime. »
C’est un peu vendeur de tapis.
Je n’ai rien contre les vendeurs de tapis.
Le 27 ou 28 décembre, je crois,
je signe sur catalogue
quelque chose qu’ils n’avaient pas
le droit de vendre
parce que le marquage
n’était fait que fin mars.
En gros j’ai acheté une salle
qui n’était pas censée exister
et du coup, je l’ai installée.
Ils me l’avaient réservée avant
qu’il y ait les ruptures de matériaux,
avec les tarifs de 2021,
avant la guerre en Ukraine, etc.
Et voilà ce que ça a donné
à Saint-Étienne.
On travaille avec un grand écran ici,
on a d’autres écrans qui sont
avec des relais un petit peu partout,
des tablettes tactiles et tout un tas
de systèmes pour travailler.
Qu’est-ce que ça donne ?
Eh bien, vous voyez, le gros avantage
d’avoir une image numérisée,
c’est qu’on peut en faire ce qu’on veut :
là, c’est à peine plus gros
que ce que j’ai au bloc opératoire
et c’est hyper centré.
Vous voyez, là, il y a l’aorte,
le plus gros tuyau du vaisseau,
et puis un anévrisme ici, qui est énorme,
et ça, ce n’est que de l’informatique,
tout ce qui est en rose.
Un peu plus bas,
c’est une artère poplitée,
derrière le genou.
Normalement, la réalité,
c’est grand comme ça.
Mais comme on est dans quelque chose
de complètement -
comme c’est numérisé et
on peut tricher sur les tailles,
on peut se mettre dans tous les angles
sans avoir à faire de rayons.
Ce sont des images
qui sont assez extraordinaires
et inimaginables encore
il y a une dizaine d’années.
A quoi ça sert ?
C’est assez simple,
notre boulot, c’est de soigner les gens
et je pense sincèrement qu’avec ça,
on les soigne mieux.
Les gens qui me connaissent savent
que je suis toujours un petit peu direct.
Moi, personnellement,
je n’irai plus dans un centre
où les gens n’utilisent pas
ce genre de technologie.
Non qu’on en ait besoin
pour chaque intervention -
ça ne veut pas dire que si on n’a pas
de la 3D, on ne sait pas faire -
c’est que ça demande
un tel investissement de travail,
de compréhension
et de préparation des interventions,
que, à tous les stades, on progresse.
Je suis convaincu qu’il faut absolument
utiliser ces technologies
pour progresser.
Donc, et après ?
La réalité virtuelle avec les lunettes,
je ne suis pas encore tout à fait
convaincu, c’est un peu lourd.
Et on a encore besoin de voir
ce qu’on fait avec nos mains.
C’est pas du tout robotisé,
on a encore des gestes fins à faire.
Mais j’ai des copains qui essaient ça,
pour l’instant,
c’est encore un peu limite.
Mais les commandes vocales,
très probablement,
parce qu’actuellement,
une grosse partie de mes gestes,
de nos gestes, ne sont pas faits
pour faire de la médecine,
mais pour organiser et faire bouger
les images, pour sélectionner, etc.
Et il y a une grosse perte
de temps et d'attention.
Donc je pense que la commande vocale,
ce serait pas mal.
Probablement aussi les commandes
gestuelles, ça, j’en suis convaincu.
On aura peut-être des choses aussi
sur nos yeux, je ne sais pas.
Mais pouvoir bouger et arranger
les choses avec les mains,
arrêter de toucher les tablettes
parce que, quand il y a de l’eau,
elles fonctionnent
beaucoup moins bien, etc.
À mon avis, à un moment,
il va y avoir des détecteurs de mouvement,
c’est très probable.
Et l’intelligence artificielle.
Chez nous, on commence
à en entendre parler
mais plutôt pour compiler
des données médicales, etc.
À un moment, les ordinateurs
vont nous dire
comment on peut faire mieux
pendant l’intervention,
nous donner des éléments
pour décider plus vite.
Ensuite, vous avez compris
que notre matériel est droit,
il est un peu rigide, etc.
et que nos vaisseaux sont tortueux.
En fait, notre matériel retord tout ça.
Et pour l’instant, l’informatique
n’arrive pas à nous donner -
On a juste une image, un moule
qui est avant qu’il y ait
du matériel à l’intérieur.
Et à un moment, je pense que
l’intelligence artificielle sera capable
de calculer et de nous redresser tout ça
pour qu’on soit encore plus précis
et encore plus performants.
Je voulais remercier aussi mon équipe.
Ça, c’était le jour
de l’inauguration de la salle.
(Applaudissements)